[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
I'm Maya Kaczorowski.
I'm a Product Manager in
container security at Google.
JESSE ENDAHL: Hi, I'm Jesse.
I'm the Chief Product Officer
and Chief Security Officer
at a startup called Fleetsmith.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: You have
a lot of titles, Jesse.
Feel free to tweet at us
later or during the talk.
So we'll be talking first about
what container security is.
So why containers
and why Kubernetes?
Well, Kubernetes makes a lot of
constructs a little bit easier
for you to manage--
things like scheduling,
so to decide
where your containers
get deployed,
lifecycle management,
how many containers
you should have up and
running, scaling to bring up
and size down sets of
containers, and load balancing,
so you can send traffic to
the right sets of containers.
But Kubernetes also has a bunch
of security features built in--
things like logging
and monitoring
to make it easier
for you to figure out
what's happening
in your container.
This is not like a log
aggregation en masse,
but gives you a lot more
than you would get otherwise.
Debugging and
introspection to figure out
what's happening
inside your containers
or to attach to your containers,
and identity and authorization
to determine who can do
what with your containers.
And more and more
of these things
are being added to Kubernetes
as part of every release.
So you're already getting a lot
of security features built in.
Running containers,
though, as a concept,
is a slightly different security
model than you're used to.
It gives you a fundamentally
different set of benefits.
So containers are short lived
and frequently redeployed.
That means you can be constantly
patching your environment.
Things that you were
doing passively before,
like patching your
OS, where you had
to take down Sunday, 2:00
AM maintenance windows,
you don't have to do anymore.
You can just patch that image
and then redeploy it passively
when a new container comes
up in your environment.
Containers are also
immutable, so you
can control what's deployed
in your environment.
By having these short
lived containers,
you have a single
enforcement point--
a single choke point
for everything that
ends up in your environment.
It's much easier to
figure out, for example,
if you're subject to a
particular vulnerability
because you know
what you've deployed.
A common reason people
don't want to use containers
for security is isolation.
You know, they say, hey, I have
this thing called a hypervisor
that I know really well
with a virtual machine
and I know it's really secure
and isolates my workload.
And until recently,
until things like gVisor,
we didn't have something
similar with containers.
So now we do, and
that's actually
one of the greatest strengths
to using containers,
from a security point of view.
And lastly, a lot of
good security defaults
in containers in Kubernetes
are one line changes.
You can follow best practices
like enabling seccomp
without taking on a lot
of the work yourself.
So it's really-- containers
allow you to think completely
differently about how you can
patch and manage your system,
compared to how you're doing
it with virtual machines.
So your mindset's a little bit
different, but a lot of things
are the same, right?
If you had an
identity management
system with your VMs, you have
an identity management system
with your containers.
If you had a network management
system-- a network security
solution, you have a network
security solution here.
You still want firewalls, right?
You still want an
IDS IPS, et cetera.
That stuff doesn't change.
So what does actually change?
A few things, which
we'll point out here.
The first is the
surface of attack.
So your container doesn't
have this hypervisor,
but it does have this
host OS that you're
running your containers
on, and the container
itself has its own OS
bundled with libraries
and dependencies.
That host OS is supposed
to be really small.
It's supposed to be something
that you can run everywhere,
that it's really easy for
you to patch and manage.
So if you're doing
containers properly
you're thinking about securing
that host OS really tightly
and patching it and
keeping it minimal.
Resource isolation--
containers have
concepts for resource
isolation built in,
like namespaces
and cgroups, so you
can use those natively
to do that without having
to bring in other capabilities.
Permission management--
so access controls
for app privileges
and shared resources
are built into containers.
But keep in mind
that containers have
access to a wider
range of sys calls
than a traditional
process would,
so it potentially is
much more powerful.
And then lastly, lifetime.
Containers have a shorter
average of lifetime.
In fact, systeg estimates
that 95% of containers
live less than a week.
What that means is
that an attacker who
gets into your environment--
she can't persist there much
longer than a week.
It's much harder for someone to
stay there without you knowing.
That being said, by the time
you figure out something bad
has gone on, the attacker
might not be there anymore.
The container might
not be there anymore.
You might not be able to do
forensics and figure out what
happened in your environment.
So this brings us a little bit
to how we think about container
security at Google.
Some of the different kinds
of threats that we see.
So things like-- the
first are the attacks
to Kubernetes peripherals--
things like credential theft,
privilege escalation, the
API compromise, et cetera.
These were things around how
you configure Kubernetes--
configure environment.
The next one are software
supply chain vulnerabilities--
unpatched vulnerability,
a new 0 day that
drops in a common library, an
issue with open source library
that you're using, et cetera.
And lastly, we have
things that really
scare people-- things
like DDoS attacks,
container escapes, flooding
your event pipeline,
compromising the nodes that
you're running on, et cetera.
And so we've grouped these
into three different areas--
infrastructure security,
software supply chain,
and container runtime security.
Infrastructure
security is about how
you secure the development
of your containers.
How do I do secret management,
networking, access management,
IAM, all of those things to
make sure that the environment
that I'm developing-- that
Kubernetes or Kubernetes engine
is secure?
Software supply chain
is about making sure
that the images that I deploy
and the binaries that I use
are secure for building and
deploying in my environment.
How do I know that they're
free of vulnerabilities?
How do I know that
they came out of my
build pipeline, et cetera?
And container runtime
security is making sure
that my container
is secure to run.
It's my traditional
sec ops team--
the people in the
[? sock ?] who are
going to have to sit there
and respond to an incident.
What can they get?
How do they know what's
happening in my container?
How do they do
forensics after the fact
and make sure that we've
gotten rid of that threat?
So the question you're
probably asking yourselves
and a lot of people
ask themselves,
and sometimes I ask
myself when I wake up,
is how do I secure Kubernetes?
It's this massive thing that
nobody really understands yet,
and that's right.
Lots of people
don't understand it.
It's so new that a
lot of people don't
know what the security controls
that come with Kubernetes are.
So that's what we're really
trying to do today-- teach you
about some of the things
that exist in Kubernetes
and in Kubernetes' engine to
help secure your environment.
JESSE ENDAHL: So
it's really important
to remember that
Kubernetes is only
the sort of middle slice
in a greater picture,
and so you don't want to forget
about securing your application
layer, your containers, whatever
your container runtime is--
maybe that's Docker.
Your virtual machines-- they're
actually running sort of below,
but today, we're obviously
talking about the middle layer
of Kubernetes itself.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah, what
are some of the components
that we have?
JESSE ENDAHL: Yeah, so there's
really only three major kind
of pieces.
First, you've got the
sort of storage layer.
You could think of that
like Kubernetes' hard drive.
That's where all of your
cluster state is going to live.
Next up, you've got your master.
That's what's
actually controlling
your entire cluster.
Next, of course,
you have the nodes.
That's basically going
to be virtual machines,
and that's where your workloads
are actually deployed.
So that's where your
pods are deployed,
and pods are really just
collections of containers.
So now we can go ahead
and walk through some
of the different things
that could kind of go wrong
at each of these layers.
So starting from the top
down, if an attacker controls
a container, what's the
worst case scenario?
The worst case scenario
is that they escape
and they're able to
attack the node, right?
If they attack the
node, they can also
control all the pods
running on that note,
and then potentially
attack the next layer up--
the master.
Or they could abuse compute,
maybe, to mine cryptocurrency,
for example.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Affect
the other workloads
that you have running so
that something else that's
really critical might not be
able to run as you wanted it
to.
JESSE ENDAHL: And
then, of course,
if they can control
the storage layer,
etcd, that means they can
create, modify, or destroy
any state in your cluster,
very similar to if someone
yanked out a hard
drive from a computer.
It's not encrypted.
They can just modify
whatever data they want to.
So obviously, that's
pretty bad, as well.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Yeah, this
is a super helpful slide.
Take a photo.
This is the kind of
thing that, when I first
started looking into Kubernetes
security, didn't exist.
And it was hard to
explain to people
why you had to
protect etcd or why
you had to protect the master.
So I'll often seen people say,
hey, I'll put one key in etcd
and I'll put one key on the
pod, and it will all be safe.
And it's like, what's your
lowest common denominator?
And getting to
something like etcd
is pretty bad, so make
sure something-- etcd is
pretty locked down.
JESSE ENDAHL: Absolutely.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Sure.
Let's jump into
security requirements.
So typically, when we're
having these kind of Kubernetes
security one on
one conversations,
there's two different
tacts that come along.
One is a set of users who just
want to have basic security
hygiene-- make sure
that they're not doing
anything fundamentally wrong.
They might have some
compliance requirements
that they're trying to meet.
If you're just worried about
this kind stuff-- making sure
you're not doing anything
particularly unusual,
then this talk is for you.
This is the basics in
that security domain.
The second set of
users are people
who might be running a product
in a more high risk industry,
and more likely to
be subject to attack.
That doesn't mean, of
course, that they don't also
have compliance regulations.
It just maybe is not the same
way of thinking about it.
And for them, this is
a good starting point,
but we'll put a link at the
end of the talk that leads you
to more hardening advice.
So how do we know
anything about this topic?
I used to be a management
consultant doing work
with financial, health
care, and insurance
companies in security, and
Jesse here leads Fleetsmith.
Tell us about that.
JESSE ENDAHL: Yeah, so because
of what our product does,
we have a really kind of
high bar for security.
And what our product does is it
automates Apple device setup,
including the OS updates,
app installations, security
settings, things
related to compliance.
And so concretely,
what that means
is buy a laptop from Apple,
drop ship it to an employee.
It boots up and it configures
itself automatically.
So all of the important
apps can install--
Google Chrome, Dropbox Slack,
your VPN disk encryption
gets enforced.
All that stuff, right?
But obviously, because of
all that functionality,
we have a need for a
strong security posture,
so that's one of the reasons we
chose Google Cloud is because
of their approach to security.
And then we also do some
things on top of that.
So we run our own Kubernetes
deployment on top of GCE,
and then we secure it with
certs issued from Vault--
HashiCorp Vault.
Awesome project.
I think there's a
talk later on, yeah.
And so all that's to say
that's where I'm coming from,
in terms of background.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So
wait, your product
lets me use G Suite
to authenticate,
and then you guys run on GCP?
JESSE ENDAHL: Indeed.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: It's like you
guys love Google or something.
It's great.
JESSE ENDAHL: We do.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: All right.
So let's talk about
the variety of things
you might want to do in
your security journey
to getting to a secure
Kubernetes deployment.
There's a whole lot of
things on this slide.
Do you want to talk us
through some of these?
JESSE ENDAHL: Yeah, so
obviously the first thing
you need to do,
especially a lot of these,
if you're running
your own cluster,
is sort of the security
of the cluster itself.
And so that's things like
restricting access to kubectl,
setting up and using RBAC for
role-based access control,
using a network policy, setting
up namespaces, and of course,
bootstrapping TLS,
which requires
that you have a
CA to issue certs
to your entire
Kubernetes cluster.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Next up--
following basic
security hygiene.
Making sure you can use your
containers for that security
benefit we were
talking about earlier--
keeping Kubernetes and
your OS and your images
and your binaries-- everything
patched and updated.
Using a minimal
OS like container
optimized OS or COS on GKE.
Using minimum IAM roles to
enforce lease privilege.
Using private IPs on your nodes
to make sure that nothing has
access from the public
internet that it shouldn't.
Monitoring access
with auto logging
and then making sure
that the binaries
that you deploy are
those that you build.
JESSE ENDAHL: Next
up, you're going
to want to prevent
known attacks,
and so this is going to be
things like disabling the built
in Kubernetes
dashboard, if that's
running in your environment,
disabling the default surface
account token.
That's something that
gets mounted automatically
into every new pod
in your cluster,
and it has some strong
permissions or privileges.
Next is protecting
node metadata,
and finally, scanning
images for known vulns.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And in the
final step of your maturity
security journey here,
preventing the impact
of a potential compromise.
So security is great.
Shit happens.
Humans make errors.
What if something goes wrong?
You want to have multiple
layers of security-- things
like setting a pod
security policy to follow
best practices like seccomp,
protecting your secrets using
things like encryption,
considering using sandboxing
to protect workloads
that need to be isolated,
limiting the identity that
pods can use to authenticate
to other parts of
your infrastructure,
and using a service mesh for
authentication and encryption
between your services.
JESSE ENDAHL: So obviously,
we don't have time
to talk about everything
on this list today,
and so what we've
optimized for is six things
you can do that are high
impact and relatively low time
investment that
should significantly
increase your security posture.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Let's
go through those six.
JESSE ENDAHL: So
first up, we have
restricting access to kubectl.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: kubectl.
JESSE ENDAHL: kubectl.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Next up, using--
sorry.
JESSE ENDAHL: No, that's it.
Yeah.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Using
RBAC, our role-based access
control to define roles.
It's basically Kubernetes'
native identity and access
management.
JESSE ENDAHL: Next up is
defining a network policy,
and so by default, all pod
to pod traffic is open.
And so if you don't
like that and you
want to increase
your security there,
you'd want to use
a network policy.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Protecting
the Kubernetes dashboard.
You might have seen some
high profile hacks recently
that take advantage
of this UI, so you
have a couple of options,
but the point is--
don't leave it open.
JESSE ENDAHL: Next is disabling
that default service account
token I mentioned because if
an attacker gets access to it,
they could use it
to do bad things.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And then
using pod security policy
to follow best
practices like seccomp
for protecting your containers.
So let us jump in.
Oh yes.
As we talk through
this, Jesse will
be talking about
Kubernetes, since he
has all this experience
deploying Kubernetes on Compute
Engine, and I'll be talking
about Kubernetes engine
and how we've deployed
those things there.
Something to keep in mind around
the shared responsibility model
here is that
Kubernetes engine takes
care of the master for
you, including etcd,
so you have some
options, in terms
of configuration of certain
features and things like that.
But they're not
your responsibility.
They're Google's
responsibility to protect,
whereas the nodes,
containers, and pods are still
your responsibility to
protect the Kubernetes engine.
And maybe at the
end of this talk,
I'll have finally
convinced you to move over
to Kubernetes engine.
All right.
JESSE ENDAHL: So number one,
restricting access to kubectl.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: kubectl.
JESSE ENDAHL: kubectl.
So the reason you
want to do this
is because kubectl is a very
powerful command line tool.
If any of you have used the G
Cloud command line tools or AWS
command line tools,
this is very similar,
but it's specifically
for Kubernetes itself.
And so obviously,
this lets you do
things like create, update,
and delete resources
within Kubernetes,
schedule pods--
pretty much anything.
And so it's really important
to restrict not only
who can run this, but
where they can run it from.
And so the way that
you can do that on GCE
is through firewall
rules and enforcing
kind of a bastion model.
And so if anyone's
not familiar, that's
where you would
have a dedicated VM
or choke point where
you say the only way
to connect with
SSH into production
is through that one
host, and then you
can create firewall
rules that restrict
where you can call the
Kubernetes API from to just
your bastion host.
And so that's what
we're seeing here.
Highlighted in blue,
you see that we're
restricting the source
tags to the SSH bastion,
the target tags to the
Kubernetes controller,
and you would just apply this
through Deployment Manager,
in this case.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: So just
follow the blue things
in the YAML file?
JESSE ENDAHL: Indeed.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Great.
For Kubernetes engine,
we have a feature
called authorized networks.
Authorized networks
lets you-- so
first of all, when you connect
to the Kubernetes engine
master, that connection
is protected using TLS
and is authenticated.
And you can further restrict
the set of IP addresses
that can talk to the
Kubernetes master
using authorized networks.
Authorized networks lets you
restrict up to 20 networks
that you'd like to
connect to using HTTPS.
Kubernetes engine-- this
feature is currently in beta.
Another feature that's related
to this is private clusters.
That is also in beta.
Private clusters gives
your nodes private RFC 1918
addresses to communicate
with the master
with and to use, anyways.
And that is
effectively implemented
as an authorized
network, so the nodes
can talk directly as
an authorized network
to your master.
Yeah.
Next up is RBAC.
RBAC is role-based
access control,
and it's how you set permissions
on individual resources
in Kubernetes.
So things like how
you set permissions
to use pods, deployments,
containers, et cetera.
Basically any resource
that you can think of.
You define the roles based
on your particular use cases,
so you would say, for example,
I need a human user or a plugin,
like my logging plug-in, to
talk to a particular component.
You'd give it a role
by binding the user
in green here to the role in
red and the set of permissions
to that particular role.
There's also a couple of
predefined roles in Kubernetes,
including things like cluster
admin for common use cases.
Now the recommendation
that we have
here is that you disable ABAC.
Sorry, let me chase back.
RBAC is relatively
new in Kubernetes.
RBAC was introduced in 1.6 and
was implemented as the default
starting in 1.8.
The security recommendation
that we have here
is that you disable
another system called ABAC,
or attribute based
access control,
and instead enable RBAC
with minimum permissions.
Now if you're already
using ABAC on premises
and it works for
you, that's great.
There's no problem there.
You don't have to
change anything.
But what we typically see
with Enterprise customers
is that they're using a role
based access control mechanism
anyways, right?
It's easier to manage.
If somebody quits
my company tomorrow,
I can just remove
them from that role,
rather than having to change
individual permissions.
So if Jesse, for
some reason, decided
to quit the company he
co-founded tomorrow,
they could just take
him off of that role
and he wouldn't have
access to customer data.
Another good use case
for using RBAC here--
I think about it as
for compliance needs.
So if I need to be able
to say, for example, who
has access to customer data?
If I only have one role
that has that access,
I can just look at who
has access to that role.
It's much easier for
me to maintain that.
JESSE ENDAHL: So we
have an example here
of what a RBAC
definition looks like.
This is from the
Kubernetes documentation,
and you can see here
highlighted in blue again that--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: It's
a YAML file with blue?
JESSE ENDAHL: Indeed.
Indeed.
We're giving the
blue team user here
cluster admin rights
in the blue namespace,
and you can see that there.
So in the metadata
section, you've
got the namespace,
subjects, the user account,
and of course down at the
bottom there is the admin role.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And
on Kubernetes engine,
it's also very similar.
So like it is in
Kubernetes open source,
Kubernetes engine enables
RBAC by default for clusters
created with 1.8 or higher.
That is, if you open your laptop
right now and go to a new tab
and create a new
cluster, RBAC's enabled.
You don't have to do anything.
The recommendation
for Kubernetes engine
is that you use IAM
to manage permissions
at the project level.
For example, using the
Kubernetes developer role
for granting access
to your cluster,
and then using RBAC at the
cluster and namespace level
to set permissions on
individual resources.
JESSE ENDAHL: Next up, we
have using a network policy.
So as we mentioned
earlier, the default
for all pod to pod
communication is open.
And so if that
scares you or if you
have reasons to
isolate that traffic,
then you can use the network
policy to accomplish that.
And so we have an example
of what that looks like.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: One
thing to point out here
with network policy, because I
often get asked this question,
is that this is really about
intra-cluster communication.
If you're thinking about
cluster to cluster communication
or service to service
communication,
this doesn't solve that problem.
You're going to want
to use something
like a service mesh like Istio.
JESSE ENDAHL: So more YAML here.
More blue highlights.
So you can see here
what we're doing
is we're restricting
the traffic from nginx,
such that the only
traffic allowed
is that that's coming from
the ingress controller
with a label of
access equals true.
And so anything that doesn't
actually have that label
won't be able to talk to nginx.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: In Kubernetes
engine, it's very similar.
You can set a network policy by
using the network policy API.
At the moment,
just using Calico.
All you have to do
is pass a flag--
this enable network
policy flag, and then you
can set a network
policy as normal,
as you would in Kubernetes.
Disabling the
Kubernetes dashboard.
So some of you might be
familiar with this dashboard.
It's the UI that's
part of the open source
version of Kubernetes
that lets you
do things like
manage your cluster,
create a new deployment, monitor
what's going on, et cetera.
How many of you actually use
the Kubernetes dashboard?
OK, so maybe like 10% of people.
That sounds about right.
Typically, if you're
using a cloud provider
or you prefer the
command line kubectl--
JESSE ENDAHL: kubectl.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Then
you are probably not
putting this dashboard
into your environment.
The reason that we
mention it is that it's
been sort of part of
some high profile hacks.
It's made some cameo appearances
in the public eye recently,
so specifically, in
February of 2018,
Tesla made the news for
having a Kubernetes console--
a Kubernetes dashboard that
was open on the public web.
This was sitting
on the public web,
not password protected, and had
access to their cloud service
account credentials.
Hackers found this probably on
Shodan or something like that
and stole the credentials,
logged in, and started mining
cryptocurrency.
That's not particularly unusual.
I think that happens
pretty often.
Tesla's not the only one.
This also happened to
Weight Watchers and Aviva
in the last couple of months.
Lacework estimates that there
are over 20,000 open Kubernetes
dashboards on the web, of
which 300 have no password
protection, whatsoever.
So this is actually a big deal.
So how do I protect myself?
JESSE ENDAHL: Well you
have three options.
You can take the most
secure and laziest option--
a rare combo there--
of just not deploying
it in the first place
if you're running your
own cluster because this
is a separate YAML file.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Another YAML file?
JESSE ENDAHL: Another YAML file.
And so you can just not deploy
it, and then you'll be secure.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
I like that option.
The lazy option.
JESSE ENDAHL: It's pretty great.
That's the option we take.
Option number two is that you
could just keep it deployed
or choose to deploy it, but with
reduced permissions associated
with the service account.
But obviously, then
you're probably
going to reduce the
functionality of the dashboard.
You won't be able to use
it to do as many things.
So that's a trade-off there.
Another option is
that you can just
stick some authentication
in front of it,
maybe using a reverse proxy that
requires G Suite authentication
or something like that.
So that's your
option number three.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: On Kubernetes
engine, we followed option two
and then kind of
went to option one.
So starting with Kubernetes
engine 1.7 or higher,
we've removed permissions
from that dashboard.
It doesn't have admin
access by default.
And starting with Kubernetes
engine 1.10 and higher,
the dashboard is just
completely disabled.
We don't deploy it for you.
If you're using
Kubernetes engine,
you probably can just use the
cloud console for anything
you'd want to do anyways--
or the command line.
That's what we recommend.
And a quick note here,
though, obviously.
These are just for
new cluster creations,
so if you have an old
cluster that you've
been updating for the last
year, please go in and disable
that dashboard, right?
That's not disabled
for you by default.
So take care of that to
make sure you are not open.
JESSE ENDAHL: So
next up, we've got
that famed, infamous default
service account token.
So it's important to
understand what this is.
This is not GCP
service accounts.
This is Kubernetes
So just to kind of clarify
that before we jump in.
Every namespace gets its
own default service account.
It's used by the pod to
assert its identity to the API
controller.
And so if you don't specify a
more specific service account,
the default behavior
is that every pod
will have this default
service account token.
It'll use it and the
permissions are fairly generous,
and so the reason
that's dangerous
is because if a
pod is compromised,
an attacker could steal and use
that token to do bad things--
to perform arbitrary operations.
And so that's sort of what
we're dealing with here.
So the nice thing is that it's
disabled by default now, as
of Kubernetes 1.8 and higher.
But if you do have
a legacy cluster
or if you are just
paranoid and you
want to make absolutely
sure it's not enabled,
you can define that in the
YAML by just setting auto mount
service account token to false.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Basically,
once RBAC is enabled,
that token still exists,
but it has no permissions.
It can't do anything.
So if you turn on RBAC,
you get this for free.
And that's kind of what
happens in Kubernetes engine.
Since we turned on RBAC
by default, as a reminder,
ABAC is disabled.
RBAC is enabled by default for
clusters created since 1.8.
That token doesn't
have any privileges
and can't be abused
in your environment.
The last thing we'll talk
about is pod security policy
and various Linux
security constructs.
So some of these, you
might be familiar with.
AppArmor is a Linux
Security Module, or LSM,
that let's you restrict
your program's actions.
Things like file reads,
writes, and executions.
It basically means
that somebody can't
run arbitrary commands
in your environment
that you might not
want it to run.
Seccomp, short for
secure computing mode,
basically filters
the set of sys calls
that your application can run.
It puts your application in
a one way, secure state where
if it tries to do
a set of sys calls
that's not allowed-- like
it tries to do something
other than sigreturn
or exit, et cetera,
the process is
automatically killed.
And so it can't execute
in your environment.
There's a pretty good default--
the Docker seccomp
default profile--
that limits about 150 uncommon
or potentially unsafe sys
calls in your environment,
and that's a good place to get
started if you're not sure
what to do in your space.
So how this is
implemented in Kubernetes
is actually very
confusing, and so we
wanted to spend
some time on this,
so people make sure
other people understand.
If you have these
different things
you'd like, like AppArmor,
seccomp, et cetera,
you define a set of
these things that you'd
like to implement in the
security context of your pod
specification.
This is not a
separate YAML file.
This is an existing
YAML file that you have.
So your existing pod
specification YAML file--
you define the security
context for the things we just
mentioned--
AppArmor, seccomp,
run written on root--
a variety of other things.
Just by defining it in
that pod specification,
it'll be enforced at container
runtime by the runtime
that you're using-- by
Docker or by CRI-O--
by whatever you happen to use.
JESSE ENDAHL: So
the other option--
if you want to do this
on more than just one pod
specification, rather
than copy, pasting
that across all
your pod YAML files,
you can enforce this globally
by using a pod security policy.
How that works is it uses
an admission controller,
which is a concept
in Kubernetes that
kicks in after authentication
and authorization.
It's sort of a third gate,
and it looks at every pod
entering the cluster and decides
whether it shall pass or not.
And so basically, if you want
kind of a global pod security
policy, you would
want to set it--
sorry.
Security context applied
and enforce that runtime.
The way you would do that is
by using a pod security policy
and enabling its associated
admission controller,
which we will cover--
the very critical step of how
to make sure that actually
happens on the next
slide, I believe.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And just to
clarify here-- the security
context is enforced at runtime,
so once the thing is running
an environment, the
pod security policy
is enforced at creation time.
So when the pod is being
created in your cluster.
So that's why it's
also extra confusing,
I think, to follow along.
JESSE ENDAHL: So yeah.
This is what I was alluding to.
It's really critical
that you actually
enable the admission controller
plug-in for pod security
policy, because otherwise,
that lovely definition that you
created will do nothing.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And
the restricted policy
is a pretty good starting point.
Do you want to walk us
through some of this stuff?
JESSE ENDAHL: Yeah,
so basically, if we
go from top to bottom here--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Blue YAML.
JESSE ENDAHL: Blue YAML.
You can see that we're
limiting the pods
from running as privileged
on the first blue line there.
The second, we're preventing
privilege escalation.
The third, we're
requiring the container
to actually run without
root privileges.
And fourth, we're
forbidding the pod
from being run as
the root group.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: And it's a
much longer file than this.
We just zoomed in on the parts
that are most interesting.
You can find it on
the Kubernetes GitHub.
For Kubernetes engine, you can
limit it in much the same way.
You just create a cluster
with a pod security policy
by passing a flag to
enable pod security policy.
Just a quick note on both
Kubernetes and Kubernetes
engine--
if you enable pod
security policy,
you have to pass it a policy.
Otherwise, it assumes
that the policy
that you passed it
is the empty policy,
and you will have no
pods in your cluster
because none of them
will match the policy.
So what's next?
So we've covered
these six items.
So quickly recap what
we talked through.
The first one-- restricting
access to kubectl.
JESSE ENDAHL: kubectl.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
kubectl by using
a bastion host for Kubernetes
or using authorized networks
in GKE.
Second, using RBAC--
so role-based access
control to define roles
and their permissions.
So that's enabled by
default since 1.8.
If you're running
on GKE, we suggest
you use IAM at the
project level and RBAC
at the cluster namespace level.
Using a network policy to
control pod to pod traffic.
Pod to pod traffic
is open by default,
so you can restrict that using
a network policy natively
available in GKE, as well.
Protecting the
Kubernetes dashboard.
Either disable it or
restrict access to it,
given that it uses a highly
privileged service account.
In Kubernetes, it's not
deployed by default,
so the lazy option
works pretty well.
And on Kubernetes engine, it
has no admin access since 1.7
and is fully
disabled since 1.10.
But if you've been upgrading
your cluster, go disable that.
Next, disable the
service account token
by enabling RBAC,
which gives that token
no actual permissions.
It's default in Kubernetes
and GKE since 1.8.
And using a pod security
policy to enable things
like the Docker seccomp profile
or other security restrictions
using pod security policy--
the admission controller.
And that's in beta in
both Kubernetes and GKE.
So we talked about
some of these things.
Some of the things that
are grayed out here
now are actually all
the things that GKE
does for you by
default. So you don't
have to worry about setting
up any of the things that
are grayed out.
I also want to point out that
a lot of the other things
are one line changes we
were talking about earlier.
Using containers--
using Kubernetes
makes these things
relatively simple.
Restricting access to kubectl,
turn on authorized networks.
Network policy-- pass
the network policy.
Set a pod security policy,
pass a pod security policy.
It's fairly
straightforward for you
to enable some of these things.
And I also want
to highlight some
of the areas that are a little
bit newer in this space--
newer ideas and concepts that
are coming to discussion.
One of these here is
verifying that the binaries
that you've built are deployed.
There's a couple of open
source projects here--
Kritis and Grafeas--
that you might
have seen from Google come out
in December around how we make
sure that what is deployed
into your environment
is actually what you
built-- what you've signed.
Scanning images for
known vulnerabilities.
You can use a partner solution.
There's open source solutions
like Clair and Micro Scanner
to make sure that you know
what's actually in images
before you deploy them.
And then further down
the line, sandboxing--
Google open-source
gVisor in May.
There's a talk on
gVisor later this week.
Do check it out.
Limiting the identity
that are used by pods.
There's a new proposal
around pod identity
in Kubernetes open source.
So if you're interested,
please do go check that out.
Check out the
GitHub issue tracker
and tell us what you
think of that proposal.
And using a service mesh for
authentication and encryption.
So Istio-- there's lots of talks
at this conference on Istio
and you saw the
announcements this morning.
So check that out, as well.
So we've been talking a little
bit about Kubernetes hardening
and GKE hardening.
Hopefully, I'm starting to
convince Jesse and convince
some of you that GKE makes a
lot of that easier for you.
So first off, GKE provides
a lot of the security
best practices by default.
You saw all the things
that were already grayed out.
We're definitely working on
having more and more things
built in by default
for you, so you
don't have to manage
those from the get go.
There's always going to be
app-level hardening and fine
tuning to do, and
protecting that top layer--
your actual application in the
shared responsibility model
is still your responsibility.
Next, GKE patches you to the
latest version automatically,
so Kubernetes engine
manages the master for you
and we patch the master
for you automatically.
You can also turn on this
feature called node auto
upgrade, and we'll patch
your nodes for you, as well.
That's a super cool,
security super power feature.
People don't realize
you'll just get the screen
patches without you
having to do anything.
That's why you guys went to
containers in the first place,
right?
You don't have to
manage that stuff.
So we'll take care
of it for you.
And the last is that
Kubernetes engine plugs
into a lot of the
Google Security
features that we already
have that exist elsewhere.
So if you're already familiar
with IAM, Cloud Audit Logging,
Virtual Private
Clouds, et cetera,
you can just use those things
with Kubernetes engine.
You don't have to worry
about learning a new concept.
We also have a ton of partners
on GKE and on GCP in general,
including some who are
on container security,
specifically.
So if that's something
you're interested in,
go check them out.
Go check out the booths that are
here at the conference today.
To learn more about Kubernetes
security and Kubernetes
engine hardening, check
out the short links.
I'll just pause here for a
second and let you take photos.
OK.
And then if you
want to learn more
on container security
at this conference,
we have a ton of talks.
So we're the first upper
left hand box here,
but there's a talk later today
on Istio and a bunch tomorrow
and on Thursday to learn more
about container security.
[MUSIC PLAYING]